[Music]  I'm on a mission to road-test the best  of Britain celebrity chef cookery  courses posing as James winter a retired  schoolteacher from Edinburgh earlier i  hoodwinked st. Delia  now I'm gonna pay a surprise visit right  this is it I'm on my way into the  Bristol City ground where Norwich are  playing away today there now then deal  is gonna be watching so I have to  quietly sort of never on the way out and  it's time for me to tell her who the  real James winter is but firstly I'm  [ __ ] myself she's liable to hit me a  [ __ ] tin of mints oh no I've lost  she's not going to be happy how are you  thank you for dinner parties delights I  had the most amazing time yeah yeah the  press play and have a look now you'll  recognise me I thought your dinner  parties delayed cost I thought was  amazing in fact so inspired I feel like  Gordon Ramsay how I did you amazing I'm  the 12th man let's be having you I had a  fabulous time you taught me how to cheat  and I got away with it